hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to akinator now this game
has been requested for about as long as
I've been on YouTube but I have refused
to play it because I thought it was a
little dumb or too simplistic but I'm
getting a lot more requests nowadays
because I imagine jack has started
playing it thank you jack so I'm gonna
get it out of the way and I'm gonna
stump akinator and I'm gonna be a big
brain smarty poo and everyone's gonna
see how much better I am than akinator
so I've got my person in my way let me
think about it okay I got it I got it I
know I'm not gonna do myself because
that would be is nor I said anything no
no does your character walk on two legs
No
who's your character male I don't know
does your character have a long tail yes
is your character a Pokemon no can your
character fly I highly doubt it
character from a video game no does your
character have jams what does that mean
are you talking space jams no is your
character a member of Mensa no does your
character walk on four legs yes it's
your character associated with half-life
series man you're going all over the
place on this one no is your character a
dog know you character a member of a
pink I don't know what a pink is I don't
think I want to know what a pink is did
you character a cat kind good did you
character really exist you already asked
this one no fat and hairy no legendary
sad no character Korean what no from an
anime no lived in the u.s. no character
from the movie yes characters linked to
a line does anyone know what I'm talking
about yet no from a TV series for kids
no movie about Viking we're already way
over 20 questions here No
Oh buttercup from The Hunger Games no I
was thinking of uh princess Jasmine's
Tiger this guy stupid jacket eater is
dumb I was obviously going for princess
Jasmine's Tiger who was out there
agreeing with me this this akinator is
stupid and and see I was right I'm
smarter than him I'm better than him I'm
more handsome than him
I obviously he is just a big fraud no
that's absolutely not correct yeah let's
see if you can get it yeah let's
continue ya idiot from Walt oh yes no
character bad no smart
come on question 30 G's baby Magnum
what's this baby Magnum no pointed ears
I don't know no I don't think so
character attack yes oh there we go
finally after like 33 questions Raja I
forgot Raja was her name his name his
name his her name
so you're an idiot but you've got it so
congratulations right on it took you a
long time but there you go
so that's that's how I make myself feel
superior to akinator cuz he just big
dummy and I'm so smart alright let's
let's let's play myself I guess why not
why not do me yes I exist
is your character famous for playing
video game yes often wear a hat no not
minecraft character Swedish no I know
who you're going for character able to
summon creatures oh I don't know many
youtubers that can do that but no live
in England no live in America sure do
character famous because of Grand Theft
Auto 5 videos not really
no related to undertale ho ho doing that
feeble about undertale I have plans for
undertale but it's just taken me a while
because so many things have gotten in my
way but I have plans for undertale just
bear with me everybody
from probably not fake [ __ ] hey it's
not fake yes does your character noscope
oh all the time
MLG 360 noscopes famous for playing dank
music no Norwegian csgo to know where
ping me yes thank you
goddamn you or you could have gotten it
on the 4th question you idiot he's a
dump took him 14 questions is who plays
dang DUP music summons creatures and
play csgo yes okay good job way to go
I've been played a lot wow question
number one is your character famous
because of YouTube I'm gonna go you I
think you all know what I'm gonna do
next yes no I don't think so often wear
a hat sometimes not often but sometimes
character Irish Wow okay which character
use hypnosis well I mean when he hits me
with his sexy eyes he uses hypnosis on
me probably not for the Balkan region I
don't know what the Balkan region is
question 6 it took him 14 questions to
get me why does what does Jack have a
good picture and then not me well I'm
not that it's a bad picture it's this
picture from like three years ago okay
you got it
good job you you know Jack better than
you know me I guess well whatever
oh all right let me think of a really
really brain stumper here let me get a
real stumpy Wumpus positively pungent
brain teaser I got one see if you can
guess along with me on this one
no does he character stand on two legs
absolutely yes except for one time when
he was on his back but that's another
story entirely
it's your character from a video game no
do you character a human being yes an
adult man absolutely live in America no
black-haired yes European
no from Japanese anime no character bad
no main character in their movie
probably character been into space no
character fight with the sward yes Lord
of the Rings no yes no character married
no born in Texas come on you know it's
from Game of Thrones
no made out of golf no no whoops I yes I
don't know what that other one was yes
that character real no character Belgian
no there you go it only took you away
too many questions but you got it Jon
Snow give you get what time that he was
on his back no spoilers about that one
but who never mind how many of you got
that I don't know if many of you got
that from what he was going on but hey
remember what I said the beginning
pioneers big dumb doofy do in a canoe
tour don't know what he's doing okay I
got another one and I'm going on an
Aladdin [ __ ] so that's on the Latin
[ __ ] Aladdin binge alright so your clue
for you guys out there is another
character from Aladdin so welcome to
legs no we're blue clothes kinda yeah a
stealth expert probably know does can
your character read minds
probably not play League of Legends no
famous anarchist oh god if he was that
would make a lot of sense but no
character a genie yes
character from a movie yes character a
victim of unrequited love
probably not character living being no
machine no group called side mitten no
yes Walt Disney there you go and I
picked this one because he's a way
better genie than you would ever be so
suck on that akinator you're inferior to
the ultimate genie
so there you go
that's my play I did I bet that's a
common one just because people want to
compare the real genie to this genie so
either way that's a kanay der I I
actually had some fun with that one so I
hope you enjoyed that to let me know if
you did in the comments down below thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to see more cool games like
this let me know in the comments below
or give me a suggestion for what game
you want to see played let me know I
always I'm open to suggestions so thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video I feel like this
would lead to a lot more problems than
just what's seen on the surface though
look like an [ __ ]